[Musique]
ça a presque pas changé c'est fou j'ai
tellement de souvenirs sur cette place
et tu vois ma grand mère elle vivait
juste là non mais attends attends de
quoi tuer le film porté par an ah oui
c'est vrai alors salive obama salue
belle-maman donc avec laura on est sur
la place de vos vacances oncav fait la
petite visite nostalgique et je vous en
fait profiter
vas-y donc ma grand mère elle vivait
juste là mais c'est ici qu'on se
retrouvait tous les soirs il y avait
deux grandes tapes style hyper convivial
qu'est ce qu'on a pu rigoler et là
c'était sur cette place que les pleins
de gens tu passé avec des crêpes et ma
tante au lieu de leur dire bonheur et
cheap et lord 6ème mandat - si tu
m'écoutes personnes se rendent des
comptes
il répondait merci aussi à tous qui
s'applique aux épingles et un jour il ya
un gars qui connaissait le truc on s'est
dit on sait quel truc mais qu'est-ce qui
ne compte pas l'écouter [ __ ] et la l2
parle ça t'intéresse en plus minces
heures s avec le gâteau ils allaient
arriver
sa soeur maury un gâteau ok allez
maintenant tu as plus qu'à l'écouter
tranquille et bah voilà c'est pas
sorcier bordel la honte et s'était assis
sur les genoux d'une inconnue
de quoi m j'étais pas du tout rentrer
maintenant je me sens pas très bien
est ce que je peux à l'infirmerie à la
mairie j'ai dit ça oui bon je vais dire
aux toilettes je peux passer un petit
peu d'eau sur le visage
je crois bien
je me fous dans la merde tout seul c'est
pas possible
[Musique]
alors salut beau-papa salut belle-maman
minceur et savait que le gâteau ils
allaient arriver là en courant et en
maintenant et s'assoit sur les chemins
verts et l'avocat pas de gâteau alors a
dit bhl dans l'est où le gâteau il là
elle se rend compte que c'était pas si
j'ai la bonne table et là on s était
assis sur les genoux d'une impunité
[Musique]
belfort en vacances j'ai pris la main de
ma mère est en fait c'était pas ma mère
pareil c'était l'inconnue de la route ça
va bien toi ouais t'as d'autres
anecdotes à raconter
je suis tous un jour mettaient d'autres
ma soeur
[Musique]
tout au plus
la statue de la liberté
tu m'écoutes way
[Musique]
une fois ici on a trouvé un portefeuille
avec ma soeur avait 4000 euros dedans du
coup on a été oh put direct c'est ici
que master a mis un coup de tête à l'un
d'eux nous avons des liens
pourquoi c'est là qu'avait lieu le
tournage de l'émission pyramide tu
m'écoutes way i feel que christophe
colomb a découvert l'amérique celtique
les déconner streamshare c'est ici que
j'ai remis en armorique au monde et
enfin soyons sérieux deux minutes
si ici que j'étais annoncé que je te
quitte est que je rentrais m6 quoi le
wimax est insupportable à jamais mais
écoutez moi j'en peux plus vivre
[Musique]
et c'est ici que j'arrête de torturer
mais non j'ai pas vraiment partie aux
mains et à l'hôtel par un aller retour
pour aller chercher ma veine de l'est
bien mais j'imagine que n'a pas écouté
pas que tu te mets de la pression comme
ça roman je sais que je parle beaucoup
si tu décroches tu le dises pas grave
est allé je profite d'avoir ton
attention pour se dire quelque chose que
j'ai pas l'habitude de dire en face je
t'aime comme tu m'écoutes oui
salut c'est aurélien alors abonne toi à
la chaîne golden moustache et cliquer
sur le caméscope si tu veux voir la
vidéo la levrette romantique
c'est une histoire d'amour mais dans un
autre genre si t'as pas du tout envie de
voir une histoire d'amour moi tu peux
cliquer sur la dernière vidéo et le
staff tout simplement parce que t'as pas
du tout à écouter vraiment sûr